maintenant le souvenir 25 ans déjà et le
mythe de claude françois perdure ces
disques continuent de se vendre et
chaque week-end et bien sa dernière
demeure le moulin de dannemois dans
l'essonne reçoit la visite de quarante y
et d'admirateurs et dans l'établissement
attenant on peut y entendre un sosie du
chanteur décidément très populaire côte
respaud fabrice dujardin on s'y croirait
presque toutes les femmes semaine ou
travers de suzy les spectateurs
retrouvent leur idole coûte françois
suit 25 ans après sa mort ils n'ont pas
oublié une seule note de son répertoire
est varié
de ma jeunesse
si j'avais à bateaux j'ai cogné ray le
chou
je me lève je te bouscule tu te
réveilles pas comme d'habitude via la
maison il ya de printemps ces fameuses
maisons chutent à moulins à danois foot
françois vécu pendant 14 ans et depuis
sa disparition
c'est devenu une sorte de mémorial qui
reçoit par an vingt mille visiteurs
autant dire vingt mille fans de tout
acabit par exemple il y a l'incollable
date de naissance 1er février 1939
taille et poids en taille 1 m 73 ennemis
poids 65 kg 95 comme un costume parfait
1793 il ya aussi ceux qui sont tombés
dedans dès les biberons ce qui est tout
petit et je me rappelle vaguement et
mais ça va donner une marge superbe et
le mes parents et à françoise moi ça
m'est rentrée j'écoute aux quatre
enfants est dans la même catégorie on
pourrait mettre les actuels
propriétaires de ce moulin les anciens
boulangers qui travaille depuis des
années à reconstituer à l'identique
l'univers de leur idole ici aussi pour
celui qui lit à même à l'intérieur un
petit musée riche de quelques objets de
l'idole autant de preuves pour rassurer
ses fans
claude françois ne sera jamais un jeu
chez
ah oui
à